ciao ragazzi benvenuti anno no puntata
di vita buttata il tema di oggi è scuola
[Musica]
pensavate che ce ne saremmo andati per
sempre invece eccoci qui all'interno
degli studios del mio studio questa
nuova serie sarà piena di sorprese e di
ospiti stupendi di novità pazzesche oggi
non succederà questo perché ci
accontenteremo semplicemente di matteo
bruno
matteo è un piacere con una
presentazione così grazie sempre un
amico uno dei motivi per cui siamo molto
contenti per questo video che in
collaborazione con actionaid che si
occupa di adozioni a distanza e una
delle cose alle quali non si pensa
spesso a quella del diritto
all'istruzione oggi noi parleremo di
mondo he roba assurda
molti i bambini nel mondo non hanno
possibilità di fare i commenti che
farete oggi però vi spiegherò tutto
quanto alla fine del video con più calma
un giorno la mia sorella gemella che
frequenta un'altra scuola richiede
disperata si possa sostituirla a
un'interrogazione di inglese in quanto
gli scrutini sono alle porte e il
rischio il debito insomma la mattina mi
presento a scuola vestita e truccata
come mia sorella e l'interrogazione va
benissimo e niente lo scoccare della
campanella io me ne vado via e ne
sorella che nel frattempo era stata per
tutto il tempo in bagno rientro in aula
come se nulla fosse prima del mondiale
chiunque ha un gemello ha fatto questa
cosa la mia stima e la mia invidia più
cocente parlando di scuola ti dico che
ho una novità
mi sono segnato l'università
quindi il giochetto che vi chiedo di
fare è indovinate qua sotto quale è il
percorso di studi che ho intrapreso
secondo me
matteo vorrebbe vinta da il vostro
momento in prima superiore un mio
compagno senza nessunissima ragione
valida ha deciso di farsi riprendere
mentre correva contro un muro dell'aula
e ci si schiantava sopra il muro
dell'aula non ha fatto niente di male
era quest'atto di cartongesso e quindi
quando ci si è schiantato contro ha
fatto un buco con il piede alla fine
hanno coperto con un pannello di legno e
non mi hanno fatto pagare niente ciao
rimando questo vocale da parte del mio
ragazzo e quarta ginnasio è andato con
la classe in gita a praga e ha
dimenticato il suo compagno di classe
sull'autobus erano stati in discoteca e
quando sono tornati in albergo non si
sono accorti che questo si è
addormentato sul sedile in una città per
la mia amica
ma di tifare per la stanza di due
compagnie di classe insopportabili poi
le professoresse cesca maroni scappammo
e cena scoprimmo nell'armadio siamo
rimaste chiuse nell'armadio tipo mura e
sentirò coloro che parlavano male di lui
è stato molto bello poi quando siamo
uscite nell'armadio mi piace molto il
fatto che l'inizio della storia sia
stavamo andando in quella stanza per
litigare cioè o ce l'hai cinque minuti a
102 e remo sbloccata siamo la
circolarità del pestrino plaus così si
sente molto spesso a scuola con c'era la
decisione di utilizzo
niente di fondato da uno vale appena
nocciola che hanno ricevuto il falco
e un minore
poveri persone perché poi tu pensi di
essere nascosto che nessuno sa che sei
stato tema è palese che sei stato tu che
fai un passo indietro tu pensi di essere
simpatico ed è per questo che lo fai
cioè tu lo fai perché in questo modo
tutti ridono 6 culla se ritorna ma quel
professore ha fatto già vent'anni di
carriera all'interno della scuola e
dell'insegnamento quante aquile quanto
in celli a cui va bene quanto i volatili
ha sentito all'interno delle sue classi
io non vorrei poter mettere le note io
vorrei poter dare punizioni corporali
come nel medioevo
a vichy io pazienza 00 ciao guscio
ospite era
corso all'orale di maturità e parlare
tutto bene dopo cinque minuti
colpo di scena
il momento l'anima davanti a tutti i
professori ora sono uscita con 100 e
lode abbiamo appena scoperto di metodo
prima bastava stretta a saperlo prima
tutti riguardo il tuo sogno dice io mi
ricordo benissimo che all'esame di terza
media sono arrivato in ritardo ma di
quanto tanto perché mi hanno chiamato
per dire ho toccate e io stavo a casa
avevo letto male sul tabellone degli
orari abbiamo ascoltato un po di
commenti deve a questo punto di
prenderci un secondo di pausa con il
segmento
allora matteo preferiresti poter
cambiare il futuro o il passato con la
sola forza del pensiero
il passato però pensa che panico che
crei come ti muovi anni fa il delirio sa
fa il delirio delirio è bello capito
almeno fai un po di caciara preferisci
meo claudio di biagio
assolutamente the guarda posso dirti
assolutamente termini
perché claudio non c'è preferiresti
ubriacarti rivelare tutti i tuoi segreti
o ubriacarti e rivelare tutti i segreti
del tuo migliore amico
del mio migliore amico cioè tutti felice
che tutto senza dubbio perché gli
scheletri nell'armadio o degli armadi ha
divisi la pre stagione con gli scheletri
al secondo della primavera scheletri
inverno
stile preferiresti porre fine alla
famiglia il mondo ottenere assistenza
sanitaria gratuita per ogni essere umano
sulla terra
pensa caxxo nate fa entrambe le cose e
al momento sta aiutando 5 milioni
persone al mondo quindi la domanda trova
trabocchetto che volevo vedere che cosa
avresti scelto come al solito pavido non
si prende una decisione della tua vita è
finito al segmento grazie matteo ciao
ciao spioni c'era questa lezione di
vestirsi ogni giorno dell'ultima
settimana di scuola
adesso tolgoi c'era anche quello di rete
intesa ma lei si chiama l'ultima
interrogazione che non nasconde nova
stupendo questa è una cosa meravigliosa
su quest anno cosa stupenda da fare che
tu fai l'ultima settimana nella quale ti
vesti come ti pare secondo me dovrebbe
anzi essere una cosa che viene
implementata quotidianamente come nel
programma scolastico ma bisogna amare
che almeno una settimana all'anno cioè
questa cosa 2 mettere invece di lanciare
uova contro gli autobus vacca di farina
contro le vecchie arte fare che ne so
all'ultima settimana di scuola della
quality traveste ecco che sempre un
qualcosa che spreca minucci boerse mi
sembra un tempo divertente come fatto
cose così a scuola io usavo fare questa
cosa di mettere un po di bianchetto sul
banco e dargli fuoco perché il
bianchetto e altamente infiammabili
freddo no no è proprio che era simpatico
il momento dopo quando c'era questa
torre vincendo chimico nella classe che
succede ha preso fuoco un'auto fuori
nella classica si vide una fiamma
una piccola via ultimo un piccolissimo
falò non si fa però io accendevo questa
piccola fiamma aspettavo quei pochi
secondi affinché l'odore fosse giuste
poi si spegne tu hai criticato quello
che faceva i versi dell'aquila io vengo
da una classe lo dico onestamente anche
ha fatto tante tante cose molti di
questi e non posso dirvela proprio non
posso dirvelo ma un giorno non ci andava
di fare la lezione abbiamo cercato di
creare un diversivo abbiamo ribaltato i
banchi quindi le entrate a tutte le
nostre mucche e c'erano quelli lì ci
vogliamo fare i fighi che stavano dritti
e poi c'era io e una serie di altri
nemici che era questo buongiorno proprio
[Applauso]
anche mio marito esaurito essere un po
nella regola ma io mai stato capito che
doveva fare così poi per carità potete
anche se volete
censura armena però abbiamo avuto il
lancio per
poter il nemico
e che per fortuna d'aglio
e avevamo un altro che non si lava la
però caso questa nostra cosa più
tranquille di tutte ciao allora io penso
che la mia naturale propensione alla
tristezza e la malinconia sia in qualche
modo da imputare alla mia maestra delle
elementari
spiego perché l'energia di natale tutte
le classi imparavano queste belle poesie
tutte colorate così gioiose sul natale
vi ricordo che un anno mi ritrovai a
recitare in piedi sulla sedia davanti ai
miei parenti con fierezza questi versi
di ungaretti non ho voglia di tuffarmi
in un gomitolo di strade la parlata nata
stanchezza sulle spalle lasciatemi qui
con una cosa posata e dimenticando
il bellissimo
bellissimo e ancora se lo ricorda pensa
allora ha ragione che un trauma aveva
una professoressa molto particolare per
un anno di filosofia
però che si era comprato una cassa con
un microfono restano col microfono ad
archetto non ci credo ti giuro e quindi
le facciamo le lezioni di filosofia con
questo a smr
non cicli però fortissimo che avete
questo passo non ci firma un volume è
mostruoso ma un genio ma ne andava in
giro anche a parlare con le persone che
ti metteva la casa davanti c è chi
bisbigliava ma quando parlo qui tira ma
su ciao
ciao sono meroni che cabala posso
aiutarti se avete al fine di questo
video ragazzi grazie mille matteo grazie
mille a voi e grazie mille aktion ed che
si occupa ve lo ricordo ancora da oltre
trent'anni di adozione a distanza
noi abbiamo raccontato quelli che sono i
nostri aneddoti legati alla scuola ma
sapete che il mio di bambini non hanno
questa possibilità e non solo non
possono avere degli aneddoti divertenti
da poter raccontare ma lo stesso tempo
non ha la possibilità di accedere a
quegli strumenti che ti permettono di
immaginare sognare e avere un futuro
diverso l'adozione a distanza uno
strumento potentissimo per poter
cambiare questa situazione bastano 9
euro al mese per cambiare la vita di un
bambino
io ho un aneddoto legato alla scuola di
quando sono stato in africa e ho visto
le scuole di questi bambini in mozambico
ho visto questa classe che stava sotto
un albero all'ombra di un albero e la
maestra giova lezione su questa lavagna
che era appesa a un ramo e io ho pensato
ma che carini che bel siparietto si in
realtà la questione è che non avevano
una classe fisica in cui stare e le
rivoluzioni perché può costruire una
classe in quei bambini possono fare
lezione e comunque azione non si occupa
solo del lato fisico e materiale del
costruire le classi i libri ma
principalmente lavora su dare il diritto
all'istruzione il diritto alla sanità e
quindi rendere queste comunità
indipendenti questa è la base lo scorso
video poi ha ricevuto da parte fosse una
generosità enorme vi prego cerchiamo di
continuare a farlo perché questo
veramente camera vita delle persone vi
lascio il link in descrizione adottiamo
un bambino a distanza la faccia del
bayern è questo qui definito
ciao
[Musica]